two of the best examples I think have
been Loki what happened to him and then
Thor and what happened to him as well
like just completely gutted from being
capable confident guys that could
overcome things to why how would you
describe what's happened to their
trajectory
I think it's
um it's a public humiliation
I think it to me the way those
characters got written and how they
evolved from let's say their initial
introduction onto the onto the screen it
felt as if the writers were exacting
some form of Revenge on on these
characters
um and taking all of the things that
made them exciting interesting to let's
just make them really stupid and let's
Eclipse them with the the their obvious
counterparts that are going to be better
than them right and that's the female
version there's a female Loki there's a
female Thor and I think
um it was less obvious with the war
where they just you know where Jane
wasn't necessarily a bad character in
the way that she was written or anything
like that but
um but they just really dumbed down Thor
you know he's
his outfit his hair the fact that he
grabs his
hammer and and uh yeah his hammer and it
looks like a witch's broom and he rides
it was just so it was so such a farce to
take a man that that is supposed to be
this God right and to completely make
him this joke and they took all the
ideas that they built out in Ragnarok
and then just he took it so much further
that uh it just it became and it was
embarrassing it was embarrassing to
watch him what about Loki
uh Loki it was less obvious but
you know it was it was similar things
that he's bumbling he's dropping things
he's breaking things you know he's he's
not aware of the mission he's kind of
dancing around and singing for some
reason and and uh forgetting that he
needs to be in Disguise and and it's
it's uh female Loki what was her name um
Sylvie she's the one who has her wits
about her and she has to remind him that
you are uh you're being a real idiot
right now and so it was things like that
that um even with Loki oh the dressing
Downs he received repeatedly right even
from um Owen Wilson's character where he
says to him like calm down for a second
you know you're or him repeatedly
repeatedly having to affirm that he's
better than the other Loki how come the
other Loki has more protection or
security than him and it's hard to then
remember that when you look back on the
first Avengers film where Loki's this
formidable uh
you know almost like I think uh nerd
erotic said this on the stream I did
last week on on critical drinkers saying
it but he said it almost it was like he
was resurrected from hell right but
that's how he was introduced into the
Avengers as uh this really formidable
force and then now he's just this
dancing monkey and he's he's no threat
at all he's in fact easily he just
transitions away from his power you know
a power hungry phase
surely though for a long time women
haven't been as represented when it
comes to superhero movies and stuff like
that is it not a good thing is it not a
an advantage that we've now got females
that are putting men in their place and
telling them what they think about them
I think it would be just as good as as
men putting women in their place and
telling them that they're not so good I
think anything that is a reaction
um that's such an intense pendulum swing
where you're you're motivated not by
storytelling or or sharing deeper human
stories but instead you're motivated by
Revenge I think nothing good ever comes
out of that it's good that there are
more roles for women that's great but
it's not good if those roles uh actually
create a false perception of what it
really means to be a woman
uh and what I mean by that is so much of
so many of the Marvel super female
superheroes are so perfect that it's
impossible to connect with them
it's impossible to know
um it you know a deep connection with a
character comes from seeing yourself in
that person's place
and if you if you do connect with these
people you think your life is perfect
and you think that you will you sh you
don't anything that wrong that goes in
your life is undeserved right and that's
a lot of the way that these stories are
written is that there's not the
traditional hero's journey there's not
the development of the power it's more
of like you're born you have the power
um and if anyone doubts it it's coming
from a place of malice right so even
with female Loki right what does Loki
say to her your you run rings around
them you're amazing how did you learn
magic I taught myself right and you'll
see that theme throughout Marvel even in
Shang Chi which is a movie I actually
liked
um uh but the hit shangshi's sister was
name I can't remember right now but uh
his sister she was not allowed to train
with the boys and she just taught
herself and she's even better than Shang
Chi right she gives him that good old
kick in the groin to prove that point
and I think what would traditionally
happen is that if someone taught
themselves anything
the idea would be that there have major
holes in their knowledge that then
um then they would be really they would
basically suffer consequences for not
knowing about those gaps and then have
to have to fill that in and then Excel
to that next level but that doesn't
happen an example of that might be the
um classic MMA Underdog Story where the
guy gets angry because the bully beat
him up I stole his girl and he goes and
kind of learns on his own but goes into
a MMA gym finally to find out that he
doesn't know grappling or he doesn't
know Brazilian Jiu Jitsu he has the
gumption and the motivation to go and do
the thing but he needs to discipline it
he needs to be able to Wrangle it within
the existing format so there's this sort
of wild Brilliance that people come in
with but it still needs to be honed in
that way yet it seems that it's
something that is self-generated at the
moment is already perfect it blooms and
Blossoms into something that was better
than it ever could have been
right right no that's exactly right so
it's I think um that's my main issues
that my problem is never with
the fact that there are so many female
characters I think what is wrong with
that really there's nothing wrong with
that I think it's that it it's rooted in
an understanding of uh of people that's
not accurate and it's espousing a sense
of entitlement that's not good on an
individual level what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]